allons dans l'information fait la une de
la presse la bbc a annoncé que le prince
william héritier du trône d'angleterre
et sa petite amie kate middleton ont
rompu après plusieurs années d'idylle la
monarchie avait cru trouver son couple
mais une fois encore il semblerait
qu'avec la famille d'angleterre les
histoires d'amour en général finissent
mal bernard lebrun les souvenirs du
mariage était déjà prêt ne manquait plus
au milieu en eau que la date de la
célébration
mais coup de théâtre il n'y aura même
pas de fiançailles selon le sun le
tabloïd le plus populaire du pays
williams 24 ans était de 25 ans ont
rompu à l'amiable raison l'armée d'abord
en décembre dernier le prince william
futur roi a achevé l'académie militaire
de sandhurst
le saint cyr anglais officiel sa majesté
bien sûr son amie kate middleton était
au premier rang venus l'applaudir
seulement voilà le prince a rempilé dans
l'artillerie
il veut devenir chef de char et se
trouve de nouveau enfermés dans une
caserne à 2h de nantes
pendant ce temps dans les rues de la
capitale quête solitaire doit affronter
le harassement des photographes
cette jeune et belle roturière filles de
richissimes commerçants étaient devenus
la nouvelle diana diana justement déjà
coqueluche des médias
je ne crois pas du tout à toutes ces
histoires de paparazzi du harcèlement et
tout le reste je pense que le prince
william n'est tout simplement plus
amoureux de kate middleton aujourd'hui à
londres a créé un south demeure de
william et de son père le prince charles
pas de déclaration ni de commentaire les
médias en sont pour leurs frais depuis
ce matin le prince william est de
nouveau le célibataire le plus convoité
au monde
avis aux amatrices une précision
toutefois le prince n'est pas pressé de
se marier il a toujours déclaré pas
avant 28 ou 30 ans